[Música]
economía en directo América ya está con
nosotros en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches bienvenido
tenemos que comenzar hablando de
Argentina esa cifra de inflación que
superó el 100% por primera vez desde
1991 que dicen allí así bueno el dato
por primera vez en 31 años supera ya los
tres dígitos y aleja cada vez más a las
metas que se había propuesto el gobierno
respecto a la inflación los datos del
Instituto Nacional de estadísticas y
censo muestran que los precios al
consumidor experimentaron en febrero Un
aumento interanual del ciento coma dos
por ciento eso es 3,7 puntos
porcentuales más que la cifra de enero
pero el dato que más preocupa es la
subida de los alimentos que aumentaron
un 9,8%, la carne y los productos
lácteos fueron los que empujaron este
aumento los datos muestran que los
acuerdos gubernamentales para detener
esta subida de los precios fracasaron en
América Latina solo Venezuela super
Argentina en inflación este aumento de
los precios
en el primer bimestre pone en duda estas
posibilidades reales de desacelerar este
año la inflación al 60% una meta que se
había propuesto el gobierno allí el
peronismo necesita controlar la
inflación para tener alguna oportunidad
en las elecciones de este año escuchemos
si las reacciones locales
nada no hay plata la gente no entiende
Entonces cómo compra
los otros días Vine le digo Dame dame
tres mandarinas dos naranjas dos banana
y medio kilo de tomate Bueno me dijo 650
pesos y que no saca todo déjamelo tomate
porque no tengo más plata No sí me
enteré que es un 100% anual no no se
puede no se puede totalmente
sí que se vayan todos Así estoy cansada
cansada cansada cansada
cansada de todo esto de los políticos de
que se pelean de que y la gente se muere
de hambre
y hablemos ahora de Estados Unidos
porque ayer el escenario es
completamente lo opuesto la inflación
continúa cediendo terreno ahí la
inflación bajó en febrero por octavo mes
consecutivo los precios se ubicaron en
el 6% interanual según los datos
publicados por la oficina estadísticas
laborales pero aunque bajó el nivel
Todavía es muy alto si se toma en cuenta
la inflación subyacente que está en 5,5%
esto ayudaría para que la reserva
Federal de ese país vuelva a subir los
tipos de interés la próxima semana pero
la inestabilidad financiera tras la
caída de silicon complica los próximos
movimientos de la Fed el comité de
política monetaria se va a reunir el 21
y el 22 de marzo y hasta hace solo unos
días esperaba una nueva subida de los
tipos la discusión Entonces era así
sería de 0,25 o de 0,5 puntos pero la
inflación ahora pasa un segundo plano
con enseguida de los bancos por el
riesgo de un contagio en el sistema
financiero goldman sachs espera una
pausa a la luz de los recientes
tensiones en el sistema bancario pero
todo está por verse la próxima semana
cuando se haga esta reunión de la
reserva Federal Jorge justamente le
quería preguntar por estos bancos que
fueron a la quiebra como ha evolucionado
esta crisis allá en Estados Unidos bueno
las autoridades de ese país investigan
si hubo Mala conducta de parte de los
directivos del banco antes de la caída
de las acciones varios ejecutivos del
silicon vendieron acciones un movimiento
que ahora está llamando mucho la
atención de los inversores y también de
las redes sociales por ejemplo de las
ventas que más llaman la atención son
las del primero de marzo ese día el
director financiero Tania al Beck
reportó la venta de 2000 acciones a un
precio promedio de 287 dólares lo que
asciende un total de más de 575 mil
dólares pero la mayor transacción fue la
del sí o gregory Becker ese mismo día El
Ejecutivo vendió las acciones adquiridas
los precios que oscilaban entre los 285
y los 288 dólares el valor total de la
venta era de 3,5 millones de dólares y
Becker obtuvo una ganancia neta de 2,2
millones de dólares justo antes del
colapso o la quiebra de este banco
hablemos ahora de despidos segunda Ronda
de despidos en meta bueno la empresa
matriz de Facebook va a recortar 10.000
puestos de trabajo meta y otras empresas
tecnológicas llevan años contratando de
forma agresiva y en los últimos meses
empezaron a despedir algunos de Esos
trabajadores estos 10.000 puestos se
suman a los 11.000 despidos de noviembre
pasado alrededor del 13% de su planilla
de ese momento meta anunció una caída de
sus beneficios y su tercer trimestre
consecutivo de descenso de los ingresos
esto es una señal de que las empresas de
rápido crecimiento incluida muchas
empresas tecnológicas se preparan para
un periodo prolongado de condiciones
económicas adversas y para el cierre la
cifra del día bueno nos vamos hasta el
Líbano la libra libanesa cayó a cien mil
unidades por un dólar la libra libanesa
se desplomó un mínimo histórico frente
al dólar en el mercado paralelo mientras
los bancos de ese país afectados por una
crisis reanudaron una huelga indefinida
y no hay muestras de que vaya a parar
esa devaluación de la libra libanesa
Jorge muchas gracias por esta
actualización es todo por el momento en
la economía aquí en directo América a
continuación ya viene el debate
[Música]